Spa Resort baden-baden is also known as
a cultural center the city has spruced
itself up for its easter festival it
opens with puccini's opera Manon Lascaux
it's a grandiose production featuring a
large ensemble on an enormous stage the
story is about love and betrayal part of
the opera is set in a harbor city that
was a big challenge for the set builders
it also involves a lot of hard work
behind the scenes during performances
large props and backdrops have to be
maneuvered into position at breakneck
speed one of the largest components of
the set is a huge ship 8 by 8 meters
mission complete see a guy so it's quite
complicated and difficult it took a lot
of rehearsal but we can manage it now
there are four backdrops each with many
large decorative elements what are the
pitfalls size or something else Mystikal
is the size and the bulk of components
the huge ship the Cyclorama the great
weight of the parties that's high let
Tiki Beach there the set was built here
in Berlin three months ago it was still
in pieces it's made up of numerous
different materials that have to undergo
a great deal of processing to become
what the set designers dreamed up since
the 1990s this company has been making
sets for theater and opera productions
around the world they've also worked for
the Metropolitan Opera in New York and
the Vienna State Opera
at peak times up to 30 people can be
found working on a single set a variety
of crafts people are on hand including
welders and carpenters
the company also employs a theater
painter it's taken him four months to
create this backdrop alone the company's
founders are based upstairs in the
office they started small making sets
for independent theaters in Berlin ok
bo-buddies Michael Young was he can look
we were making music together we also
made our own instrument cases we
realized that we were much better at
making things than making music then it
just got bigger and bigger we move from
one workshop to another larger one was
ever host milanesa TFS Kosovo and they
needed the space as the company grew so
did the size of the sets they built
being entrusted with more ambitious sets
was an honor for the company and a huge
challenge
you can see it's basically a craft but
its connection with art keeps us
interesting but as a whole the Opera
will be performed just three times in
baden-baden but the set will go on to
the Metropolitan Opera in New York
you